bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette autre
édition d' espace autochtone en direct
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
gouvernance autochtone et pour ce faire
nous avons invité alexis wawanoloath
date qu un jour guadeloupe willy
également nos chroniqueurs habituels
isabelle picard bonjour bonjour et
mathis hervé bonjour alors petite
présentation de vous alexis on a dit sur
notre page facebook que vous étiez le
premier autochtone a siégé à l'assemblée
nationale du québec qui a le plus
l'obtention du droit de vote ont atteint
69 église et rapide
oui on va en parler avec isabelle parce
qu'isabelle a gagné recherche justement
sur budget bastien mais avant on va vous
présenter vous alors vous avez donc été
ce premier autochtone a siégé à
l'assemblée nationale du québec donc
depuis depuis que les autochtones ont le
droit de vote
nous sommes encore et toujours le seul
oui pourquoi il ya peu d'intérêt pour
moi j'imagine qu'un manque d'intérêt
le niveau de gouvernance provinciale est
souvent perçu comme quelque chose de
lointain
l'évaluation historique fiduciaires ont
souvent été avec la couronne fédérale
donc si dans la vie de tous les jours
plus si on regarde je pense bouger
véhicule à val-d'or designers et les
écrits cas ils font face à des
institutions québécoises vivent cela
durera six ans à la sûreté du québec a
repensé à la santé 40 ans à l'éducation
avant tous les dossiers qui font sortir
la commission vient au cours des
derniers mois tout ce qu'on a entendu
oui
donc c'est sûr que ça peut amener encore
une certaine distance mais d'accord vous
êtes devenu député vous n'aviez que 24
ans qu'est-ce qui vous avez donné envie
de vous lancer en politique à ce moment
là bas j'ai toujours le de manciet pour
le parti québécois
j'ai toujours
une intérêt pour maintenir qui au second
d'âge était dans le conseil qui disent
je faisais du bénévolat de jeu à cet âge
là j'ai une famille quand même assez
politique ma tante monique si oui c'est
une des fondatrices de femmes
autochtones du québec
mon père gaston larouche s'est présenté
pour le hérie 1 à l'époque
donc vous voyez que des deux côtés il ya
cette fibre politique et à ma mère qui
est une artiste quand même bien reconnue
dans le monde des premières nations
toutant a mené à percevoir que on peut
aller au delà dans le fond de l'identité
essentialiste qu'on essaie de souvent
nous impose
puis c'est ça c'est une question de
rester en reste donc au secondaire je
m'identifiais très fiers main comme un
oui un autochtone mais aussi comme
canadienne parce que je pensais que ça
allait de soi et de fil en aiguille à
force d'être dans un milieu québécois
j'imagine mon père les québécois puis
comme j'expliquais il ya un passé
nationaliste mais si je me suis même
fier aussi de québec donc
après ça des tests comme le colloque as
mené à avoir des réflexions justement
comme quoi les combats nationaux dans le
fort aux québécois qu'il a quand les
combats nationaux des premières nations
ont pour but de survivre dans le temps
de survie nationale louis annonce donc
j'ai vu une convergence dans les limites
nationales à quelque part et donc après
ça techniquement parlant comment je me
suis retrouvé à devenir député
je suis revenue à val d'or avant 12 ans
je me suis précision vous dites à val
d'or mais en fait vous êtes né à vous
cheminez à la datcha benaki dos d'âne a
mis d'accord mais mais votre communauté
d'origine c'est odanak since i wanna do
what car donc à valdes ensuite à mon
retour je me suis inscrit dans une
attestation d'études collégiales au
service à l'enfance dont mon métier
avance éducateurs axe par oui et j'ai
commencé à m'impliquer au cégep
paraissant par le biais des centres
d'amitié autochtones parle cela dans
leur atelier dit qui m'a fait une place
bon ben je dois vous
deux résidents les jeunes et de tout y
est sans doute hilton à baba je suis
devenu quelqu'un très très impliqués
dont je devenu premier président
francophone l'association nationale des
jeunes autochtones englobant donc de
faire une aiguille je discutais avec
quelqu'un puis que tous ceux qui étaient
impliqués avec le bloc québécois gilles
bouyssou tennis de lyon tandis que j'ai
commencé à m'impliquer avec le bloc
québécois ce moment là dans campagne
électorale qui se passait pendant le
temps des fêtes le 2 mai trois ans si je
me rappelle bien
et quelques mois plus tard je me suis
présenté au à l'assemblée générale du
pays qu ou chez le président me disent
mais tard je te laisse la place de la
jeunesse est une belle relève puis moi
j'ai dit ok ben moi je m'en avoir pour
devenir député
bazin qui finalement personnes pensaient
que j'allais pouvoir gagner parce que je
m'étais contaminés ce qui était quand
même assez populaire auprès de la
communauté d'affaires avec tous les
candidats d'envergure qui aurait voulu
que les études en abitibi et l monsieur
bois tu la quittes achète alex cruz et
ondine ont fait que je me suis retrouvé
avec le seul cas d'accord mon corps est
pas tabou pour les mamans ou je suis
dalmat j'ai fait une bonne campagne à
l'investiture peut être est ce une bonne
campagne électorale puis et vous avez
été élu voilà maintenant vous avez
laissé la politique pour vous tourner
vers le droit pourquoi aubin la
politique tant que magazine apolitique
s'est jamais sous
j'ai après bon avoir été député j'ai été
directeur du développement des
ressources humaines du bien-être social
à l'action donc j'ai travaillé à faire
en sorte que les gens puissent trouver
un chemin dans leur vie pour avec la
conjointe d'un conjoint de l'époque la
mère de mes enfants comme ça venir un
compromis pour qu'on puisse se
rapprocher de sa famille qui était plus
dans le sud du québec qui aussi donner
des racines abénaquise donc on a choisi
odanak et de fil en aiguille je me se
présente on conseille de vendre j'ai été
conseiller au conseil des abénakis d'eau
pendant deux ans où j'avais des dossiers
tels que la sécurité publique
l'éducation du territoire et jean une
grande volonté justement de reprendre en
main notre gouvernance de reprendre en
main ce que je vais proposer un
programme dense en présentant comme chef
j'ai perdu donc d'avis faux faux fin
faut faire deux coureurs puis ça va
changer et un adversaire la communauté
je vous imagine mal comment j'aurais pu
me trouver un emploi comme intéressant
j'ai fait le tour et ce pour envoyer des
cv pour l'éducateur sais pas si on veut
pas le savoir plage talent au cégep je
me suis ennuyé parce que je n'ai je pas
mal et autodidacte dans la vie et je me
suis dit bon ben je me souviens toi
parce que c'est quelque chose que j'ai
tout le temps en fait la défense des
droits des enfants des gens qui
cherchent du travail de mes frères et
soeurs abena king puis je voulais
continuer à faire ce ans en arrière
quelque chose qu'ils arrêtent à moi mon
tour de droit va être à moi dix mots
simples et resteront travail en
politique peu importe le travail qu'on
fait prêt à l'époque le net et y conte
mais dans notre travail on peut tout le
talent se faire tasser sur des mensonges
oui oui ok alors on disait premier
autochtone à l'assemblée nationale comme
députée donc depuis que les autochtones
ont le droit de vote mais c'était il ya
50 ans au québec
c'était un petit peu plus longtemps au
canada dont nous sommes en 1960
mais il ya eu l'udj et bastien avant
donc c'était à la fin 2009 124 jusqu'à
fin exactement 1980 à 27,06 bout de
temps ou si 1944 mais en fait candidats
défaits il nous dit avec armes égales il
était qui lui est en fait pour deux
parce qu'en réalité depuis que la loi
sur les indiens a été instauré les
autochtones ne peuvent pas se présenter
ne pouvait pas se présenter en politique
là jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient le droit de
vote s'il ne mettait pas de côté leur
statut oui c'est une émancipation
forcier sud est donc effectivement il y
avait une des clauses dans la loi sur
les indiens qui faisait en sorte que
notamment si on allait à l'université on
était émancipé notamment si on voulait
avoir le droit de vote et donc de voter
il fallait s'émanciper son voulait
devenir l'ennemi des banquiers terrain y
avait il y avait plusieurs clauses comme
ça s'écrit perfectionnement c'est enfin
on perd on perd carrément son statut
lisse et droit et au noir sortir de la
communauté donc comment est ce que lui
dit bastien qui ne pas été démentie paix
ont pu être député et n'aurait cessé
tout un sagan et on m'a posé la question
à plusieurs reprises et ce matin j'ai
décidé d'aller fouiller le conseil de la
nation huronne wendat m'ont été d'une
grande aide
à ce niveau là notamment stéphane picard
au niveau des archives mario gros-louis
aussi qui est historien et finalement ce
qu'on me dit c'est que monsieur le juge
bastien vivaient hors de la communauté
mais jusqu'aux lignes sur la communauté
donc il vivait dans une maison très beau
domaine qu'on appelle le domaine du
buisson qui est situé à l'orée de ville
il donc il était considéré premièrement
comme un indien hors réserve donc ça
c'est une chose qui aurait pu faciliter
le fait qu'il s'est présenté comme
député malines
il ya une autre hypothèse en fait on
avait vous le savez dans toutes les
communautés on avait un agent des
affaires indiennes et à wendake et
pendant longtemps c'était la famille
bastien qui était de père en fils ou à
peu près agents des affaires indiennes
dans la communauté et là c'était mort et
bastien qui à l'époque était si je me
trompe pas son frère ou son cousin et
qui est l argent des affaires indiennes
et c'est un qui décide et qui gardaient
le statut à perdre et donc il y aurait
eu une petite entourloupe possiblement
donc c'est une des hypothèses mais
plusieurs hypothèses comme ça qui fait
en sorte que monsieur le débat ci n'a
quand même jamais perdu son statut puis
par suite au fait qui a été député à
l'assemblée nationale il a été grand
chef de la nation huronne wendat et tous
ses descendants ont conservé leur statut
dont on sait qu'il n'a jamais été
immense
il ya eu des petits trucs comme ça on
dit aussi que wendake et donc leur rêve
était tellement depuis tellement
longtemps historiquement près des
québécois bonbons et canadiens français
et qu'ils étaient assez assimilés aux
yeux du gouvernement pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de facto toujours ça me démange pas
si oui voilà intéressant bon on va
refermer cette page d'histoire sur
facebook il ya des gens aussi qui ont
commenté en disant oui mais y en a eu
avant mais là on est rendu dans les 6800
l'époque du bas-canada donc une tout
autre réalité c'était avant la loi sur
les indiens alors on n'embarquera pas
sur ce terrain là mais embarquant sur le
terrain de la gouvernance autochtone
aujourd'hui comment est-ce qu'on peut
devenir en fait maître de sa destinée
c'est un peu ça revendiquer la
gouvernance
comment on se fait ça se fait avec les
processus qu'on voit habituellement des
négociations intervient mais ça serait
aussi dans l'action directe tout
qu'est-ce qui était haïe d'au moins 10
les résultats de ces actions directes ne
reviennent souvent faire en sorte que la
gouvernance vont changer
est ce que on avait eu la commission
royale sur les peuples autochtones sa
réalité de la crise donc est ce qu on
avait eu la permission sur les femmes
autochtones a porté disparu ce rapport a
été dans les drones aux morts dans la
mobilisation
je pense que ça peut être une étape
justement de se réapproprier un cadre
quitte à nous aussi parce que qu'est-ce
qui est difficile avec une négociation
qui avec l'autonomie gouvernementale
comme elles soient proposées c'est qu'on
reste quand même dans un cadre où on va
vous déléguez vous on va vous
reconnaître des pouvoirs et on va vous
les délégués c'est tout à la couronne
qui délègue ce pouvoir là on n'est pas
dans un partage la souveraineté comme ça
devrait être parce qu'on n'a jamais
vraiment céder nos territoires au québec
la panda baie james puis qu'est-ce qui
est traitée par la convention de la baie
james
puis après ça si on se réfère votre été
numérotées ils n'ont pas été faites dans
des mesures où il y avait du
consentement où il y avait le libre
consentement donc à la banque mais il
faut falloir voir quelques temps la
fondation soit du canada si on veut
garder ce sujet optique fédéraliste
canadienne ou d'un éventuellement dans
une république québécoise va falloir en
arriver à des traités conditionnelle ou
on se partage la souveraineté puis où se
partage de souveraineté là ça fait non
seulement sur le territoire aussi sur
les individus on a pensé à toutes les
les autochtones qui vivent en ville oui
exactement parce qu'elle cette réalité
là aussi ce sont des gens son territoire
ils sont ici en vinyle ouais donc d'un
côté pour avoir ça qu'ils ont côté on
voit que dans notre monde actuel le
libéralisme la propriété individuelle
on est dans la faillite de ce
aujourd'hui on s'envole un instant de
l'instruction on est dans la sixième
heure dans cette élection la rentrée
prochaine
l'ère de l'humanité et il serait peut
être intéressant de renverser ou si les
perspectives où on a tout le temps été
influencée dans notre identité qu'on
pourrait appeler constitutionnel par des
pouvoirs coloniaux
il serait intéressant de voir justement
que nos valeurs nos façons de faire
notre philosophie basée non pas basé sur
la propriété individuelle puis sur le
temps linéaire comme on le voit dans la
philosophie libérale qui ne qui nous
contraint à beaucoup d'égards de base et
ça sur le territoire sur le fait que
l'humain est partie du territoire
d'ordonner une nouvelle identité à un
éventuel état qui pourrait se faire avec
les annales autochtones n'ont pas dominé
les autochtones
alors quelle structure ça pourrait
prendre une structure ça pourrait
prendre dans les travaux j'ai fait
dernièrement puis les réflexions j'ai eu
il faut qu'il ya eu une restitution dans
une certaine mesure il n'y aurait pas de
justice on peut pas juste parler de
structure tout se focalise restitution
puis la gestion doit se faire dans le
point de vue économique de point de vue
culturel
d'un point de vue plus global ou 6 2
parce que la restitution c'est pas juste
le territoire territorialement ça va
très important parce que comme j'ai dit
dans beaucoup dans la majorité des
peuples des premières nations
le territoire est centrale donc la
restitution va falloir qu'elles soient
non seulement territoriales mais
culturel moi par exemple mon arrière
grand mère il ya repêché par les la
benaki comment on peut ramener justement
le faire quand on nous a enlevé notre
culture vraiment on peut
ça peut être économique on ne s'est pas
invitée à participer à l'économie en
général on nous attachons nous à vue des
deux comme des nuisances on a commencé à
émettre des réserves quand on est devenu
une nuisance pour l'exploitation de ce
territoire car le blocus de napoléon
l'autre bord qu'ils les anglais sont
venus chercher leurs bois ici pour faire
un voyant navy on était plus des
partenaires de commerce immunitaire on
était devenu l'ennemi sens parce qu'on
allait chercher la ressource sur le
territoire puis avait désactivé donc
comme là on ne fait pas dissipée à cette
économie l'hôpital c'était quand
hamilton ou si prompts à voir novara
parce que si on prend tout le temps même
modèle occidental capitaliste qui
détruit on arrive finalement vous même
résultat pire on on est plus qu est-ce
qu on y revient juste qu'est ce que le
people à la société dominante et là vous
parlez de restitution les pouvoirs en
place au niveau du temps fédéral que
provincial oui c'est cela que ça s'est
senti la participation des autochtones
dans vos salles aussi dans des
institutions qui devrait être permanente
je les mets en vie par exemple qui ont
une commission parlementaire permanent
pour les affaires ma vie dans le monde
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas avoir un forum
permanent comme c'était inscrit dans la
loi qu'il reconnaissait les peuples
autochtones en 1985 la première en
amérique du nord qui vous connaissez les
autochtones avait ça dans son corps qui
devrait y avoir un forum permanent de
consultation
on n'a jamais appliqué ce boulot de la
loire et en quelle année 185 c'est pas
vieux
c est ce que éventuellement on pourrait
avoir une réforme de nos institutions
représentatives t on parle d'un d'avoir
un pétale des fois en deuxième chambre
qui serait la chambre des régions pour
une représentation de gnl en plus de
représentation par la population il
serait temps d'avoir une chambre des
régions et des nations où il pourrait
avoir des représentants des régions et
leurs représentants aux hommes et femmes
de chaque nation quand m avec taille est
question d'un site et oriente aussi qui
touchent des premières nations
or on a aidé comité spécial puisque
c'est ce comité ne soit spécialement
consulter oui dont il existe toutes
sortes de modèles dans le monde
c'est juste une volonté et le politique
pour la tipp ses solutions là ont été
décrites dans des commissions
parlementaires comme la commission
royale sur les peuples autochtones
c'est juste qu'on n'a jamais eu le
courage politique de mettre en action se
confondront d'action directe
on n'oublie pas la volonté politique
n'est pas encore là en fait ben brik
tout drôle tu faisais des belles paroles
je m'en suis voulu donner chance au
courant au début de son mandat
bon ben si et de bonne volonté on va
voir qu'est ce qui a amené métier au
bout de la ligne après les belles
paroles demande a encore soif dans les
réserves qui donc ça alors justement
parlons-en des soeurs donc des femmes
on pourrait repartir un peu dans
l'histoire parler des structures
politiques qui existait avant que les
blancs arrive avant que les européens
arrivent où la femme avait un rôle
central isabelle ah oui oui ça c'est
certain
ne serait ce que dans les sociétés
recueillait nous c'est très bien décrit
d'ailleurs dans la littérature notamment
dans les relations des jésuites
on voit que les femmes et on le sait de
par tradition
les femmes c'était elle qui nommer les
chefs civils donc il y avait des mères
de clans dont un pour chaque maison
longue et donc ses ailes pour chaque
clan et c'est elle qui nommait le chef
civil et c'est elle aussi qui démettait
le chef de ses fonctions si le chef ne
faisait pas là où est donc la femme dans
les sociétés recueil n on le sait on le
sait aussi que chez les algonquins qui
avaient un mode de vie différent qui
était davantage basé sur la survie
puisque bon il se déplaçait plus souvent
la faim avait son mot à dire dans ce qui
se passa dans la communauté est ce que
c'est le temps de se déplacer est ce
qu'on voit là est ce que est ce qu'on
entre en conflit avec tel ou tel clan
telle nation la femme nicole o'bomsawin
qui est une anthropologue d'odanak me
disais en trop que quand les femmes
n'étaient pas d'accord pour que les
hommes partent phare raid ou bon une
bataille oui ben elle s'essaie de
fabriquer les armements les vêtements
qu'ils devaient porter donc et lvl
trouver un moyen de finalement des
rechutes et oui oui oui se doit d'être
n'était pas d'accord final donc ça c'est
quand même assez intéressant il n'y
avait pas de rapports de pouvoir basée
sur le genre disons à la période pré
contact c'est-à-dire qu'il faut pas
c'est pas la manière de voir les choses
chacun homme femme
enfin aînés avaient un rôle à jouer dans
la société
un rôle qui était pas plus important au
moins six heures que les hommes vont
faire des trucs qui demande plus de
force physique
on s'entend mais notamment dans les
sociétés aériennes passé les femmes qui
s'occupait des champs de l'horticulture
elles étaient plus souvent avec les
enfants puisque c'est les enfants aussi
qui les aidaient on a chacun veut son
rôle les hommes partent et à la grande
chasse les femmes pouvaient faire de la
petite chasse alentours oui donc et
c'est comme ça que la société
fonctionnait un peu sous un modèle du
cercle dont on parle souvent comparé des
sessions d'automne
donc la hiérarchie elle était plus ou
moins là quand même
le chef oui il avait un rôle c'est sûr
mais c'était un rôle de porte-parole et
encore même aujourd'hui dans les
sociétés maroc
j'ai été mariée avec un chef à cannes et
s'attaquer longtemps et c'est ce qui ce
qu'est ce qu'il disait et dit moi je
suis un porte-parole c'est la population
et dont les femmes qui viennent
m'instruire sur ce que j'ai à faire les
décisions qu on d'apprendre
est ce lié à l'eau était gardé fallon
société noël et notamment malgré
l'arrivée de la loi sur les indiens
parce que le singe changer le rôle des
femmes complètement certain journée la
politique absolument maintenant pourquoi
exactement une loi sur les indiens beige
sur tombé sur une citation du rapport
annuel du ministère de l'intérieur
puisque avant d'être le ministre le
ministère des affaires saint etienne
c'était le ministère de l'intérieur qui
s'occupe des indiens et donc la citation
dit ceci j'ai envie de vous lui a choisi
une autre loi sur les indiens repose en
général sur le principe selon lequel les
indiens doivent être maintenus sous
notre tutelle est traitée comme les
pupilles où les enfants de l'état
la sagesse et le devoir nous enjoignent
de faire accéder l'indien par
l'éducation ou d'autres moyens à un
niveau supérieur de civilisation en
l'encourageant à assumer les privilèges
et les responsabilités d'un citoyen à
part entière alors c'est assez clair ce
qu'on peut faire avec la loi sur les
indiens et comment est ce qu'on arrive à
ce finalement à l'assimilation parce que
c'est ce qui est sous titrée donc
lorsque je viens de vous lire mais on
change les systèmes de a à z les
systèmes existants chez les autochtones
autant chez les rocailles uns que chez
les algues hockey et j'ai tous les
autres peuples autochtones du canada
entre autres on va mais on va mettre les
autochtones en réserve donc c'est à
partir de ce moment là qu'on va faire ça
on impose aussi la patrie linéarité
parce que notamment chez les rocailles
et c'était la femme qui déterminait le
clan des descendants et là à partir de
ce moment là les européens disent non
non non c'est le père qui est le chef et
donc vous allez prendre le nom du père
et qui prend toute l'autorité phibel
vraiment absolument et on impose aussi
un nouveau système politique
et là j'en viens au fameux conseil de
banque oui et là ça change du tout au
tout par rapport à ce qui se faisait
dans le passé notamment
c'est un système où on va
installer un système hiérarchique
finalement parce que le chef vont avoir
des pouvoirs plus importants que les
autres alors que c'était pas ce qui se
faisait avant c'est un système qui est
qui et phallocrate parce que c'est
seulement les hommes aussi qu'ils
peuvent être nommé comme chef
donc ça aussi ça change les choses alors
que les femmes avaient bien qu'elle
n'était pas chef
elle était mère de clan elle avait
vraiment leur mot à dire un gala en fait
c'était juste dit aujourd'hui oui oui ça
change et des familles chez a changé les
aideront la wii les audiences étaient ça
donc pendant des décennies il faut
savoir aussi c'est que le conseil de
bande
si alexis le déjà vu la première version
de la loi sur les indiens et puisque les
conseils de bande
quels étaient les pouvoirs qui avait pas
grand chose donc de pouvoir
réglementaire de la fratrie je connais
c'est ça exactement non c'était le
pouvoir de soude entre les mains de la
junte
c'est exactement le jeu vaut en rire le
fameux majorité dont je parlais tout à
l'heure que toujours là il rapportait on
a encore des tirs la prison gérait tout
est géré même si le chef faisait pas
comme le ministère voulait qu'ils
fassent ils pouvaient le démettre de ses
fonctions
donc les réels pouvoirs l'été où c'était
vraiment la jambe et l'agent des
affaires un témoin ils avaient donc la
femme vaut perçue par les européens à
l'époque il faut savoir que en europe
bien sûr la femme mais c'est elle qui
s'occupe des enfants
puis elle a pas le droit de vote non
plus alors ici bas on veut que les
femmes autochtones et le même niveau de
pouvoir si je peux m'exprimer ainsi mais
on n'a pas vraiment vu de nos
enseignements non mais c'est social
gardons quand on fait des comparaisons t
on voit lundi comme on est capable donc
pas capable au sens de la loi
les femmes étaient des incapables aussi
à ce moment donc une incapable qui se
maria avec la capable donc un homme
blanc d'oeuf même capable d'un capa qui
se mariait avec un incapable
tout à fait là la rolls de l'euro de la
femme est devenue complètement passée
fleurs le rôle de la femme autochtone
est devenue nettement passif à partir de
l'imposition de la loi sur les indiens
et comme alexis le 18 août alors ben
comme quand une femme autochtone marié
un allochtone donc un non autochtone
mais elles perdaient automatiquement son
statut il devait sortir de sa communauté
et ses enfants également n'allait pas
avoir le statut moss prix de la position
de sa place parce que c'était ça dans le
fond c'est au regard d'un point de vue
philosophique l'immense patients sont
gamme eco steve et l'émancipation s'il
se sortir de l'étau minorité
donc là on sortait par l'émancipation de
notre état d'un mineur sauvage de
pupille de l'état et on devenait un
adulte aucun citoyen on s'entend - oui
oui tu as tout à fait raison et ça ça en
est un bel exemple les femmes par contre
vont se battre
à partir des années 70 c'est donc comme
c'est dans mon caractère fort les femmes
vont se présenter en cour notamment
elles vont organiser des activités dont
un peu plus activistes et elles vont
elles vont gagner et en 1985 la loi sur
les indiens vont être changées avec la
fameuse loi health et 31 qui modifient
finalement là sont les est que ces
femmes ont aussi beaucoup de courage de
ce son si non seulement battu contre les
institutions gouvernementales puis le
système gouvernemental mais souvent
quand on prend notre conseil de banque
où il voulait plein service et ses
patrouilles a reconnu qu'il savait mais
gaby notamment à ax les qui est
ben oui tout accès au lieu qui était une
moc d'oganawa gay qui s'est battue
notamment contre son propre conseil de
bande et y en a eu d'autres
et donc il y aura plusieurs amendements
par la suite aussi en 2010 en 2010 est
un peu dans le même sens pour que non
seulement les femmes qui ont perdu leur
statut plus leurs avoirs et leurs
descendants également oui donc ça c'est
une chose et c'est à partir de ces
batailles la des années soixante dix que
plusieurs mouvements et organisations de
femmes autochtones qui ont vu le jour
notamment l'association des femmes
autochtones du canada et femmes
autochtones du québec et laon ce qu'on
fait on étudie le sort des femmes ont
partagé ensemble et on veut se faire
entendre faire entendre la voix
autochtone la voix de la femme
autochtone dans ce qui se décide au
niveau de nos communautés mais peut-être
de maintenant on va beaucoup plus loin
que ça en vaut maintenant au niveau
provincial au niveau fédéral donc tout
ce qui touche les femmes autochtones
on veut la femme autochtone veille à oui
mais alors depuis quand elle est revenue
en fait depuis quand elle est allée chef
elle peut devenir chef dans les
depuis quand elle peut soit je le
saurais pas dire par exemple mais je
sais que la première qui a été grand
chef c'est chez nous à wendake et c'est
jocelyne gros-louis en 1992 où 93
donc ça fait pas tellement longtemps
s'est décembre il ya encore aujourd'hui
au québec plusieurs arrêts à sion où il
n'y a jamais eu de femme chef autochtone
il y en a eu chez les mâles et c'est y
en a chez les algonquins bon mais il ya
plusieurs autres nations où il y en a
jamais eu
par contre si on regarde au niveau des
postes de conseillères où certains
diront les petits chefs s'animant comme
on les appelle là selon les communautés
ces vins entre 20 à 40% qui vont être
des femmes autochtones finalement autour
de la table des chefs donc ça c'est
quand même pas mal à faire vite et non
au canada ces 87 femmes cheffes sur 1
633 donc c'est pas ça pas beaucoup non
plus au québec y en a sept
donc c'est un endroit ni quand même loin
en nous mêmes loin alors aujourd'hui est
ce que les femmes autochtones justement
réussissent à se faire entendre parce
qu'elles sont si peu nombreuses encore
dans le
même politique ben en fait c'est
qu'elles ont trouvé des moyens j'oserais
alternatifs notamment qu' on a parlé
tout à l'heure à donne aux morts ce sont
des femmes autochtones lyon débuté le
mouvement en saskatchewan notamment oui
et au québec aussi ce sont deux femmes
autochtones donc cela donne au moins
bons qui avait pour but de s'insurger le
compte des projets doit mahmoud du
gouvernement fédéral ont valu au québec
c'est melissa maulin dupuis vie à l'ewi
leader bien sûr absolument donc ces
mouvements là les femmes se sont
beaucoup inscrit là ils ont beaucoup
milité elles étaient ils ont organisé
des manifestations il était un peu un
peu partout où elles prennent beaucoup
plus de place aussi dans les médias donc
ça c'est quand même intéressant c'est
une belle manière de se faire entendre
également lieu une démarche également la
marche amun notamment avec michèle
audette il ya pas tellement longtemps au
début des années 2000
les femmes vont faire débarquable
parfois la barre câble sur la 138 me oui
notamment
donc elles vont aussi utilisée lors pour
dénoncer pour faire entendre leur voix
donc c'est vraiment par des mouvements
parallèles qu'elles vont qu'elles vont
trouver leur voie et on les entend elles
sont en fait on le constate de très
nombreuses sur la voie à ceux à
s'exprimer en fait dans le domaine
public
des fois beaucoup plus que les hommes
autochtones on le voit ici avec les
invités qu'on reçoit espace autochtone
énormément de femmes très peu d'hommes
sauf alexis les conseils de bande si on
quand on parle de gouvernance autochtone
quelle est la place des conseils de
bande dans une gouvernance la moderne
contemporaine bas et à l'infini lundi
des nations elles-mêmes je pense comment
on peut se réapproprier nos façons de
faire traditionnels
à concilier la vie moderne parce que la
place des conseils de bord est quand
même aujourd'hui assez central dans les
communautés moi je trouvais qu'à titre
de conseillers j'avais plus de pouvoir
dire est qu à titre de député du fait
que les budgets qu'on contrôle sont plus
proches de nous soucie de ce fait aux
danois qui est une communauté qui a une
santé financière tu vois c'est bien dans
ce qu'on peut faire de quoi on a les
moyens de le faire aussi mais on n'est
pas pris à la gorge avec des déficits
structurels comme on peut voir dans
d'autres communautés qui font en sorte
que la démographie faire la sorte que
dans ces communautés nomades si une
bonne gestion c'est ça peut être assez
doux financière mais bon tout ça pour
dire que la odanak
le rôle du conseil de ballon peut être
très important maintenant c'était par
tous les membres de la communauté
je pense que dans une communauté comme
au danemark leur rôle du conseil de
vente doit être assez accepter la
particularité qu'on a nous c'est que
même la majorité notre bonne vieille à
l'extérieur la communauté on est sur
2000 3000 vatin on et 556 à revivre sur
la communauté
donc la grande grande majorité votre
part la poche ou way plus d'interactions
avec son conseil de vendre
c'est dans la réappropriation justement
comment on fait pour rejoindre
gouvernance toutes nos membres qui ne
sont pas sous réserve
c'est les structures réserve gouvernance
quitter ce qui m'a permis de me
développer sa grande partie son label en
fait c'est que je voulais juste a ajouté
que à votre question si le conseil de
bande et reconnu ça dépend vraiment des
communautés parce qu'il ya des
communautés entre autres chez les
moments où il ya une forte proportion de
jardy traditionalistes qui n'est pas
absolument qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas
le conseil de bande puisque c'est un un
héritier du de la loi sont des
indications qui vont avoir leur propre
système de gouvernance on peut baser sur
ce dont on a parlé tout à l'heure où
l'air de clans qui sont pas encore
présentes dans les communautés notamment
à gagnoa gay merci moment là c'est
difficile de se mettre ensemble quand on
veut vouloir faire changer les choses là
ouais non c'est pas évident parfois on y
arrive
puis d'autres fois on n'y arrive pas et
c'est clair et la saison voix selon les
communes les communautés alors chez les
abénakis ça a l'air de se passer
relativement bien dans la mesure où elle
un rôle du conseil de bande et quand
même bien accepter notre défi c'est le
remède rejoint tous nos membres qui sont
pour son panneau si j'ai regardé où je
travaillais chez les amish des abeilles
à lac-simon conseil de bande
un hall central chi chi le monde n'ont
pas joué de vivre avec parce que c'est
souvent ou si on pas de son départ en de
80% de la population vit sous le
bien-être social
ben c'est le conseil de bande qui gère
ça c'est conseil de bande qui va gérer
des ou citons logement si conseil de
banque qui gère une école qui va gérer
le plus gros employeur
c'est le plus gros employeur dans les
communautés parce que justement on est
encore pas nié dans un système de
dépendance économique
oui alors c'est difficile de l'ignorer
alors là mathis et là elle pour nous
parler de ce qui se passe au nunavik
parce qu'en fait il ya la région inuit
du nunavik qui a commencé des
discussions en matière d'auto
détermination
les quatorze communautés de la société
makivik qui les représente la ont signé
récemment une résolution qui a ouvert la
voie à des nouvelles discussions qui est
dans notre comment sort on n'est pas
dans un début de négociation aux
questions qui depuis des dizaines
d'années et est présente au nom n'avait
en fait jamais les choses un peu en
comptait que cette résolution elle a été
signée récemment le 21 mars lors de
l'assemblée générale annuelle la société
matis m'activer qui représente les
inuits de la région est
donc à cette réunion il y avait des
membres 14 communautés inuit
principalement des membres des conseils
du spo la société makivik et des
représentants des corporations foncière
et dans le fond la société makivik elle
prépare le terrain depuis sur
l'autodétermination depuis déjà
plusieurs années pour ceux qui nous
écoutent et qui savent pas ce que la
société makivik c'est l'organisme
l'organisation de revendications
territoriales qui est écrit au terme de
la convention de la baie james et du
nord québécois 75 puis donc elle
s'occupe de tout ce qui promotion du
développement économique social culturel
vous l'avez dit donc elle est beaucoup
dans la préservation de la langue de la
culture de l'identité là l'éducation des
inuits donc le sillon revient un peu
lente en jeu pour remettre un peu les
choses en contexte il ya un an
exactement mais 2018
à l'issue d'une réunion qui avait réuni
tous les grands organismes du minadt vic
la société makivik a été mandatée de
former un gouvernement autochtone basée
sur les valeurs renault est la langue et
nos petits tout le patrimoine et
l'identité
ensuite dans les mois qui ont suivi au
mois d'octobre dernier ont commencé des
négociations des discussions que le
gouvernement fédéral et la société
makivik pour établir un protocole
d'entente sur pour orienter les
discussions à venir ce qui se passe
depuis le mois d'octobre à peu près et
plus récemment au mois de février
il ya une deuxième rencontre encore une
fois de cette réunion qui a rassemblé
les grands organismes du nunavik et la
société makivik et a été mandatée de
former un groupe de travail en fait qui
chargé d'élaborer une constitution pour
le nunavik donc qui préside cette course
est ce groupe de travail la semmaris
aymen vous la connaissez sans doute ccl
et les militantes inuit de longue date
pour les droits désigner des étudiants
la communauté de l'uqam gear solid
jacques et elle a été notamment ancien
président de la société makivik de
l'inuit tapiriit kanatami qui représente
les inuits du nord canadien où il a mené
ces lexiques mais non moins de louis et
puis du conseil circumpolaire inuit qui
représente les stars nationales
c'est pas tout l actrice et ambassadrice
du canada aux affaires circumpolaire et
elle a contribué à contribuer à la
rédaction la déclaration des nations
unies sur le droit des peuples
autochtones
donc elle une négociatrice en chef pour
les pour le pour cette question si et
elle préside le groupe de travail dont
ont rédigé cette constitue exactement
donc le l'échéancier l'ouest qu'on en
est en ce moment le ce groupe de travail
là doit se réunir ce mois ci pour
établir un échéancier et voir dans
quelle direction ce qui sont donc
l'objectif c'est de probablement et
faire des consultations publiques dans
les communautés pour prendre le pouls de
la population voir quelles sont les
priorités les enjeux libre cette fois ci
mais est-ce que c'est pas encore
déterminé si vont se rendre dans chacune
des 14 communautés du nunavik parce
qu'elles ont lieu plusieurs raisons
l'enjeu financier est important les
coûts des déplacements s'approchèrent
oui oui j'ai là bas et puis l'échéancier
qui est assez serré donc ce qui va se
passer c'est que les consultations
publiques vont avoir lieu ils vont
ensuite rédiger une version préliminaire
qu'ils vont soumettre à la société
makivik est la dernière étape en fait ça
va être de la faire approuver ou non par
cette réunion qui réunit donc les
différents organismes et ça c'est une
question moon
c'est une question de mois parce que si
tout va bien l'objectif c'est de déposer
la version finale au mois de septembre
dont on est déjà au moins on est on sait
exactement les déplacements on est bon
il ya plusieurs communautés à visiter
donc voilà où est ce qu'on en est
exactement dans quoi si tout va bien si
au moins septembre
donc est-ce qu'on se dirige vers un
deuxième référendum je vais venir
parce qu'il a déjà eu un c'est encore
trop tôt pour le dire vite les
discussions boys se sont pas encore
évoqué ce qui c'était peut-être le
premier référendum
alors ça c'est passé en 2011 le 20 avril
2011 référendum sur la création d'un
gouvernement d'union à vic
à l'issue de ce référendum 66% de la
vignotte les hémodynamique ont voté
contre et contre dans toutes les
communautés en majorité dans toutes les
14 communautés sur les repris 4000 4200
personnes qui se sont exprimées
ça a été un aboutissement de quarante
années de négociation assez houleuse
entre la société makivik le gouvernement
fédéral et le gouvernement provincial
et puis en fait longtemps aurait permis
aux élèves de se doter d'un gouvernement
qui réalise très les finances les
abranis pâle et puis l'éducation et les
soins de santé
donc rien sur le terreau et c'était ces
enjeux la principale source des
négociations actuelles c'est comment on
fait finalement pour exploiter le
territoire pour la société dominante
comment on fait pour parce que le but de
ces ententes là c'est le but du col des
analystes d'établissement c'est la prise
des ressources du territoire acquis son
territoire pour pouvoir mieux c'est
approprié et c'est souvent le problème
de ces négociations là c'est qu'on va
vous donner
on va nous donner des pouvoirs sur la
culture sur l'éducation sur des choses
mais c'est un centre de notre point de
vue philosophique sans écriture dense et
c'est juste une façon nous rend
obsédante alizés en donnant deux trois
petits droit sur la culture
c'est pour ça qu'on a juste 22 de ces
ententes là au canada de signer on n'a
pas plus que six jeux notamment la
question territoriale
mais en fait les jo reyes qui a été
beaucoup cité par après après le
référendum qui explique un peu le rejet
majoritaire n'y a eu plusieurs choses
le manque ou s'il ya eu le monde
c'est en fait c'était une entente qui
répondait pas suffisamment aux
aspirations politiques l'absence de
nouveaux pouvoirs ça a énormément cité
qui était finalement donné aux inuit est
ce que c'était pas des pouvoirs un peu
accessoire finalement le manque de
transparence aussi de consultation
auprès des inuits et puis de garanties
en matière de protection de la langue et
de la culture donc bon alors ça c'est
des raisons qui ont été cités est ce
qu'on se dirige vers un autre référendum
comme je le disais encore un peu tôt
pour les mecs à mener si c'est ce que
les gens demandent ils sont des groupes
de travail tout va aller dans cette
direction là j'ai contacté la société
m'activer qui vous demande pas voulu me
donner de plus d'infos sur les priorités
que les échéanciers à venir mais comme
audi mairie saimone c'est que au terme
de l'assemblée générale annuelle qui
avait lieu au mois de mars
il ya quand même un désir de faire les
choses différemment le camp 2011 je
pense que à prendre un peu de ce qui
s'est passé donc ça sera voir le on
attend on attend les prochaines il
tranché à suivre il nous reste peu de
temps mais j'ai quand même une dernière
question est ce qu'on devrait
reconnaître les nations autochtones
autochtone et ça ça va être une qui sont
tellement larges comme troisième ordre
de gouvernement canada ben j'ai fait un
essai qui portait sur l'identité
concessionnels autres tonnes dernière
mais puis conclut et comme ceux
justement où on devrait s'en aller vers
un partage j'ai pas du tout partage de
la souveraineté au lieu d'une délégation
de la part de la couronne qui délègue à
ces sujets fédéraux provinciaux
ben oui on devrait avoir que ce soit
dans une redéfinition du canada où que
ce soit dans une république québécoise
à terme les deux les deux projets
conventionnels pourrait être guillamat
sans cela c'est oui il faudrait avoir
une reconnaissance constitutionnelle et
on devrait le faire par des traités
concessionnels qui fera en sorte qu'on
partagera le territoire on partage nos
compétences ont en partage mais aussi
des valeurs parce que je pense que les
sociétés dominantes qui composent le qui
sont sur le territoire ce qui n'a
d'autre part ingrate avantage apprendre
l'art autochtone sont pas sanary
l'humanité isabelle un dernier mot je
pense que nous avons de bonne foi merci
beaucoup alex sur leur bonne le wat
ce sera un plaisir de vous réinviter sur
ce plateau si vous avez des choses
vraiment intéressantes à nous dire
d'ailleurs si vous avez envie de
commenter de réagir également à ce qui a
été dit sur le plateau
ne vous gênez pas la page facebook et là
vous le vous y allez quand vous voulez
bien sûr et vous réagissez
et puis on aura sûrement l'occasion de
revenir sur ce dossier là parce que la
gouvernance autochtone c'est un sujet
immense il ment c'est infini et sur
lequel on peut passer plusieurs semaines
merci à tous les trois aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup merci isabelle a un vrai
bientôt
et puis merci mathis et la semaine
prochaine je connais déjà le sujet mais
je vous le dis pas en fait c'est une
surprise vous verrez la semaine
prochaine mais sans y perdre
intéressants comme celui ci d'ailleurs
alors je vous attends vendredi prochain
au revoir
[Musique]